hello I'm here to present the honorary
Oscar to Sidney the man who has been
directing movies for almost 50 years
it's not the years being honored it's
the quality and isn't quality the
measure the measure of an artist from 12
Angry Men to the pawnbroker - Dog Day
Afternoon and all the years since and in
between a Sidney lament movie as a
signature a stamp of individuality a
point of view a feeling John Ford Alfred
Hitchcock Robert Altman they have a
signature a character if you will that
make you want to buy a ticket see their
movies and it's that character which has
defined a city limit movie his real
kinetic energy you were there as the
story was being told I remember as a kid
watching Jason Robards jr. in a fabulous
performance in a television production
of Eugene O'Neill's The Iceman Cometh
I was so inspired by it it influenced
everything that followed in my life as
an actor it was directed by Sidney
lament and then I was lucky enough to be
directed by Sidney what does it direct
to do to quote Sidney a directed directs
he directs you where to go what to do
sends you there in mind and body the
script instructed me to rob a bank
Sidney told me exactly where to go what
to do and there I was robbing a bank he
made it happen if you pray to inhabit a
character Sidney was the priest who
listened to your prayers
help make them come true I used to love
to watch Sidney direct and so did others
I mean a self-propelled torpedo a
whirling dervish on a set fast he
brought you to life in rehearsal and
then he got you ready and when you were
ready you didn't have to act because the
process of becoming the character had
already been set in motion and
Sydney was the camera as an old village
poet put it to me in the 60s
if you dig it it's yours I dug Sidney
Lumet back then
I dig him now because what he had to
give I took and made mine I'm forever
grateful along with all the other actors
and writers who have benefited so much
from Sidney's genius
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen could be back
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you you're very kind and
I thank you from the time I did my first
movie I needless to say like everyone
else started to fantasize about Oscar
and I was lucky enough to be nominated
on the first movie so I started to
fantasize about the speech and I was
real smart aleck and I thought I would
say something like I don't want to thank
anybody I did it along I wasn't true but
I thought it'd be a way of getting a
little attention when Frank Pearson
called me about receiving this one of
course I started thinking about the
speech again and I realized if I totaled
up all of the thank-yous that you know
I've heard in all of these years I
wouldn't be able to thank all the people
that I really want you it's and I'm not
just talking about the glorious talents
that I've worked with on both sides of
the camera but there are so many with
whom I've never even worked that I owe
so much I mean how do I thank Spielberg
and Scorsese and Coppola and how do I
thank Giambi go and and call dryer and
Willie Wyler and Kurosawa and Buster
Keaton and I'm not mentioning the ones
that I really stole from what about the
Epstein's for writing a line like here's
looking at you kid or wilder and diamond
for well nobody's perfect or farrago for
mother of god is this the end of Rico so
what I guess it comes down to is I I'd
like to thank the movies I know that
sounds general but it's very real to me
I've got the best job in the best
profession in the world so I just want
to thank all of it and of course the
ones who paid more Jews than I have
thank you PI D a me Jenny see you later
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]